es la relación dada por el conjunto de
pares ordenados mostrado abajo una
función antes de que intentemos
responder a esta pregunta recordemos lo
que es una relación y qué tipo de
relaciones son funciones en una relación
tenemos un conjunto de números que
podemos pensar que son la entrada de la
relación le llamamos el dominio
puedes verlo como el conjunto del número
sobre el cual está definida la relación
y también tenemos un conjunto de números
que puede ser visto como la salida de la
relación o el conjunto de números que
está asociado con el dominio el cual se
denomina el rango y es un concepto
bastante simple supongamos que tenemos
el número uno en el dominio el cual está
asociado a través de la relación con el
número dos en el rango entonces podemos
sostener que la pareja ordenada 12 es un
elemento del conjunto ordenado que
determina la relación estas son dos
maneras de representar lo mismo para la
relación quizás también puede establecer
que si tenemos el número dos está
asociado
en el número 2 entonces tenemos que la
pareja 22 también pertenece a la
relación y observa que estoy
estableciendo las asociaciones aquí lo
estoy haciendo visualmente y aquí lo
estoy estableciendo como pares ordenados
supongamos ahora que tenemos el número 3
y el número 3 lo vamos a estar asociando
con digamos el número menos 7 entonces
tenemos 3 como a menos 7 también como
elemento de la relación ahora bien una
relación como esta en la cual si tomo un
elemento del dominio puedo establecer
claramente a qué elemento del rango está
asociado también es conocida como una
función y en un momento te daré un
ejemplo de una relación que no es
función básicamente una función es una
relación en la cual si tú me das un
elemento aquí en el dominio
yo puedo establecer
cuál es el elemento del rango
correspondiente en ocasiones se llama
mapeo podemos establecer un mapeo entre
el elemento del dominio y el elemento
del rango si tomamos el 1 lo vamos a
mapear con el 2 si tomamos el 2 también
lo vamos a mapear con el 2 si tomamos el
3 lo vamos a asociar con menos 7
entonces esta relación de aquí es
obviamente una relación pero también es
una relación que es una función que va a
mostrar ahora lo que es una relación que
no es una función para esto de nueva
cuenta dibujo lo que sería el conjunto
dominio y lo estoy poniendo así como una
nube indefinida mostrando que no te
estoy dando todos los puntos sobre
algunos de ellos y digamos que está
nuevo rosa por acá es el rango digamos
que en esta relación y lo voy a hacer de
la misma manera como lo construimos acá
arriba supongamos que tenemos aquí el
número uno que está asociado con el
número dos aquí tenemos las parejas
ordenadas 1 2 y que también tenemos que
el número 2 está asociado con el número
menos 3 número 2 con menos 3
y que además de eso al número uno
también lo asociamos al número uno
también lo asociamos con el número
cuatro al asociar el 1 con el 4 también
tendríamos entonces la pareja ordenada
1,4 entonces aquí ya tenemos una
relación establecida con su dominio de
hecho si esta es toda la relación el
dominio es tan solo los números 1 y 2
pero que lo que sucede aquí en
definitiva es una relación pero ya no es
una función y esto ya no es una función
pues si tú veas un elemento el dominio
yo lo puede establecer claramente a qué
elemento del rango está asociado
situadas por ejemplo el 1 está asociado
con el 2 está asociado con el 4 no
podemos saber exactamente con cuál
término está asociado el 1 la diferencia
en la función que tenemos acá arriba
donde que es lo que hace una función le
das 1 a la función la función te regresa
2 le das 2 a la función la función te
regresa 2 habiendo planteado eso
resolvamos el problema por acá veamos
primero cuál es el dominio
de esta que definitivamente es una
relación puede ser una función pero es
una relación veamos cuáles son los
valores de x o cuáles son las entradas
de esta relación aquí tenemos el número
menos 3 luego menos 2 luego el 0 lo aquí
tenemos al menos 2 menos 2 ya lo
incluimos aquí y finalmente tenemos el
número 3 positivo por acá esos son los
elementos del dominio son las posibles
entradas valores que pueden ser
asociados con otros valores a través de
la relación ahora el rango aquí las
posibles salidas o los números que están
asociados con los números del dominio el
rango aquí entonces son el 2 el 4 el 5
que tenemos aquí
de 6
y el 8 la podría haber escrito el rango
y el dominio como nubes como lo hicimos
aquí en cambio estamos especificando
claramente todos los números que
pertenecen tanto al dominio como al
rango vamos a establecer ahora cuáles
son las asociaciones -3 está asociado o
está mapeado con 2 - 3 mapeado con 2
no tenemos que menos 2 está relacionado
con 4
-2 relacionado con cuatro y luego déjame
hacerlo un poco más ordenado esto para
que no nos confundamos vamos a ordenar
lo mejor -3 está asociado con dos voy a
usar ahora otro color para indicar que
menos 2 está asociado con 4 tenemos aquí
que el 0 está relacionado con 5 en
ocasiones se dice que 0 estaba creado
con 5 menos 2 que está mapeado con 6 y
esto es interesante porque menos 2
también está mapeado con 4 y está
marcado con 6 como aquí lo está
indicando finalmente boyos otro color
aunque ya usted casi todos finalmente 3
estaba pegado con 8
está mapeado con 8 y la pregunta es es
esto una función para que esto sea una
función cada elemento el dominio tiene
que estar mapeado a un único elemento
del rango entonces qué pasa con -3 si
pones -3 como letra la función la salida
va a ser dos si pones menos dos como
letra la función va a haber confusión
porque las salidas 4 o la salida es 6 en
este caso no sabemos si las salidas 4 o
las salidas 6 y debido a esta confusión
esto no es una función tenemos un
elemento del dominio que mapea sobre
varios elementos del rango entonces ésta
de aquí no es una función no es una
función